le fiscaliste luc godbout est avec nous
ce soir pour répondre à vos questions
bonsoir le goût de boue bonsoir gérald
scullion on reçoit beaucoup de questions
sur la prestation canadienne d'urgence
qui arrive lundi sur la subvention
salariale
on va y aller tout de suite le godbout
parce que il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
questions ne reçoit des centaines pour
ne pas dire des milliers alors on voit
si toute une première est ce que les
employés doivent être au travail pour
que l'employeur ait droit à la
subvention salariale
il faut aussi de baliser qu'est ce que
ça veut dire être au travail donc
évidemment c'est pas nécessaire d'être
dans le lieu normal ou le se passe le
travail le donkey et plusieurs employés
qui sont en confirmant donc ça c'est
paul qui d'être dans l' usine par
exemple est ce qu'il faut de faire du
télétravail ce non plus je crois que
c'est par eux que le critère important
c'est d'avoir un salaire de la part de
l'an de l'entreprise et dès lors
l'entreprise vous êtes admissible si
elle respecte les autres critères le
chute du revenu brut de 30% dans un mois
pour elle se qualifier à la subvention
est donc toujours demeuré officiellement
à l'emploi de l'entreprise
exactement je suis orthophoniste en
pratique privée je fais de la télé
pratique mais il ne me reste que deux
clients mon agenda après le 6 avril
est-ce que je m'inscris à la prestation
canadienne d'urgence où j'attends après
mais du client et l'homme
malheureusement pour avoir droit à la
prestation canadienne d'urgence il faut
être inactif pendant 14 jours
consécutifs et sans revenus durant ces
mêmes 14 jours là donc on comprend que
un travailleur autonome qui métier qui
garde un petit peu de clients et qui est
actif pendant qui n'est pas inactif
pendant 14 jours n'aura pas droit à des
prestations canadiennes d'urgence à cet
égard là par contre on sent beaucoup
d'ambiguïtés des gens qui perdent une
grosse part de leurs revenus qui reste
seulement un petit revenu d'appoint
faudra attendre d'autres aspects que la
semaine prochaine il ya des règlements
qui viennent précise et juste si haut
pour gagner un petit peu de revenus mais
pour le moment
selon la loi la réponse est claire et si
vous avez été vous avez pas été inactif
pendant 14 jours vous qualifiez pas donc
c'est important ce que vous venez de
dire parce que effectivement il ya des
ajustements quasiment quotidiennement
un par les gouvernements sur les
différents programmes pour pour ajuster
certaines iniquités j'ai une compagnie
de services à ceux ci unique je ne
reçois pas de salaire juste des
indemnités kilométriques
est-ce que j'ai droit à la prestation
d'urgence alors pour avoir droit à des
prestations canadiennes dur genre il
faut avoir gagné 5000 dollars en 2019 ou
dans les 12 derniers mois et le foncier
de voir c'est quoi gagner 5000 dollars
au minimum on parle de revenus d'emploi
de revivre travailleurs autonomes on
parle également de prestations comme
vous au régime québécois d'assurance
parentale
malheureusement des indemnités
kilométriques c'est un remboursement de
dépenses de voitures sur la base du
kilométrage fait ou alors ce n'est pas
un salaire et ce n'est donc pas un
revenu admissible et donc non cette
personne ne se qualifie pas sur cette
base de la prestation canadienne
d'urgence c'est très clair autre
question lui que j'ai perdu mon emploi
principal mais j'ai un contrat
d'entretien ménager dans un commerce
on me paie 1000 $ par mois le 1er de
chaque mois
est ce que je peux demander l'aide à
partir du 15 puisque cela fera 14 jours
sans salaire
la question c'est scier des personnes
qui sont payés une fois par mois ils ne
deviennent pas des cibles au brillant
pour autant si elle travaille pendant
tout le mois donc la question c'est
d'être 14 aux inactifs et sans revenus
si la personne travaille pendant tout le
mois
elle ne se qualifiera pas au programme
de prestations canadiennes d'urgence
très bien si mon employé a
habituellement un salaire annuel de 80
mille dollars
est-ce que je peux le réembaucher à 58
mille sept cent par année le temps de la
pandémie pour ne pas qu'ils
n'accueillent me coûte plus de 25 % de
son salaire ou je dois absolument le
rémunéré au même salaire qu'avant la
pandémie
là on revient à la subvention salariale
d'urgence du canada qui est annoncé un
peu plus tôt cette semaine il a
lorsqu'on lit les documents techniques
on voit beaucoup de phrases du ministre
mais ça reste des souhaité on dit par
exemple on devrait continuer de payer ou
faire de son mieux pour payer l'employé
ou au même salaire qu'il avait avant la
crise
faire de son mieux dans le contexte
actuel dont on compresse est un peu
un peu flou alors si un employeur rey
rappelle un employé le réembaucher lui
offre 58000 8,58 1700 il va donc avoir
droit à 75 % de subventions salariales
sur ça et là personne recevrait 1128
dollars par semaine
en rémunération employeurs et
subventions du gouvernement
ma petite fille de 15 ans a travaillé
l'an dernier dans un tim hortons a gagné
5177 dollars elle peut donc réclamer
l'aide financière même si elle n'a
aucune charge financière sauf ces
petites sorties bon gars il faut
préciser un peu donc elle respecte le
premier critère qui est d'avoir gagné
plus de 5000 dollars en 2019 ou dans les
12 derniers mois mais les autres
critères c'est il faut que la petite
fille perde son emploi où seul son
emploi à cause de lakovic donc il faut
que l'ipcc elle était présentement en
mars un emploi il faut qu'elle le perdre
à cause de l'égo vide est resté inactif
pendant 14 jours consécutifs pour se
qualifier à la prestation canadienne aux
gens si c'est le cas oui mais le
pauvrement de dépenses elle va avoir
droit à la prestation canadienne
d'urgence dans son coq et voilà un
travailleur de la sépaq qui devait
commencer sa saison à la mi avril et qui
est retardée que lui arrivera t'il s'il
ne fait pas assez d'heures cette année
pour avoir son plein chômage l'hiver
prochain alors là on comprend qu'on est
pas vraiment dans la prestation
canadienne du rien d'urgent son on va
plutôt dans le régime régulier de
l'assurance emploi
on comprend que les gens qui ont des
emplois saisonniers comme ça à chaque
année perdent leur emploi à chaque année
doivent retravailler suffisamment de
temps pour être heureux qualifiés
l'assurance emploi alors là c'est sûr
que s'ils n'emploient est retardé
ça peut mettre en péril ce sont donc
deux semaines malheureusement je n'ai
pas de réponse il faudrait voir s'il y
aurait pas d nouveau règlement qui vont
être faits à l'assurance emploi pour
permettre à cette personne de rester
qualifier mais pour la maman peut pas
répondre en plus en détails très bien je
suis chef à domicile travailleurs
autonomes et tous mes contrats depuis le
15 mars ont été annulés
est-ce que j'ai droit à la prestation
d'urgence travailleurs autonomes qui
perd tous ses contrats
cl après plus de 5 m 2
de revenus en 2010 neuf ou dans les 12
derniers mois qu'il perd c est contre de
travailleurs autonomes à cause de
lakovic 19 et qui les 14 joueurs
inactifs
oui il va avoir droit à la prestation
canadienne d'urgence de 500 $ par
semaine pendant pendant quatre 4 mois la
baisse de 30 % de revenus n'est pas
atteinte à cause des gros contrats en
début d'année l'on est sur l'enjeu de la
subvention salariale
par contre avec deux semaines
d'inactivité on a une baisse dramatique
de plus de 30% par rapport au début de
l'année
est-ce que je me qualifie pour la
subvention salariale dans la subvention
salariale qui était annoncé cette
semaine la chute de 30% c'est pas une
chute annuelle s'était pas une chute
trimestrielle c'est une chute mensuelle
donc il faut bien comparer mars 2020
avec max 2019 ils sont une chute de 30%
on va se qualifier qu'on va avoir droit
à la subvention salariale pendant quatre
semaines
on va refaire le calcul pour le mois
d'avril avril 2020 par rapport à avril
2019 encore une fois si une chute de
revenus bruts de 30%
on va avoir droit qu'à trop de semaine
de subventions salariales on va le faire
le même exercice pour mais également
parfait autre question le conte encore
un petit peu de temps ça chante ma
demande d'assurance-emploi était
inactive et que je lis réactivée après
le 15 mars en raison de la cobi de 19
serait jade miscibles à la prestation
canadienne d'urgence lorsque pour
comprendre que cette personne leur
recevait déjà de l'assurance emploi dans
les derniers mois dernières semaines et
pour une raison de revenus ponctuels
avait mis ses prestations d'assurance
emploi sur la glace est donc mis la
demande inactive elle le réactiver
donc elle redémarre ses prestations
d'assurance emploi c'est les prestations
d'assurance emploi qui vont se
poursuivre et non elle n'a pas droit à
la prestation que des dizaines d'urgence
dans son contexte
ok on a pu tant pour les questions mais
moi j'en ai une
une parenthèse pour finir 30 secondes
les étudiants qui ont fait un peu plus
que 5000 $ qui n'ont pas encore trouvé
d'emploi d'été là ils n'auront pas
nécessairement accès à la prestation
d'urgence n'est ce pas non l'oeil aux
potes pour le moment c'est encore le
flou il faut cesser un an
emploi donc un étudiant qui était en
stage présentement qui se qualifier et
que son stage pour un effet abruptement
oui il y aurait droit à la prestation
canadienne d'urgence sous d'autres
critères
mais quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'emploi qui
espère en avoir cet été c'est loin
d'être là qui va pouvoir avoir droit à
la prestation canadienne d'urgence je
pense qu'on vient de défaire les projets
de milliers de jeunes qui passaient
touché 1,2 mille dollars
toutacoo par mois au cours des prochains
mois ça n'arrivera pas nécessairement
pour squatter qu'ils se trouvent un
emploi pour l'été prochain
le godbout merci